we have this tweet here from uh
mackenzie from cnbc said if you want to
send ten dollars from canada el salvador
via western union's app it's a 3.24 fee
from the moon wallet to the chivo wallet
it's 10 cents chivo de chivo it's free
boo kelly's new bitcoin wallet could
cost companies like western union 400
400 million dollars a year
see ya we already held the funeral for
western union
i'm sure you guys are nice people but
you're dead to us so so this is exactly
kind of like the vision of what the
blockchain could be is that you cut out
the middleman
and
the people it doesn't fall on the people
right well so
there's two key things to take away from
this right and this is really if you're
watching at home right now we're gonna
start getting into some of the weeds
over the next couple of shows about uh
some of the the ways from like an
investor perspective you can understand
that the trend is our friend when it
comes to uh to bitcoin and not just
around price so for example let's start
first with just the fees when you look
at a piece of technology what you're
looking for is a 10x or more improvement
right you can't just simply have a
2x improvement from a technology
perspective or it's too evolutionary
what you need is for real technology to
have true disruption as you need 10x or
more and some of that is qualitative
like you just kind of feel like hey this
is so much better but some of it is also
quantitative and so look being able to
look at the fees for example and say
wait it's a 3.24 fee if i use a legacy
system it's 10 cents if i use this
system then that's a 10x improvement you
really understand like oh wow this is
super disruptive right
the second thing is
in the legacy system if i go to western
union and i want to send money to
somebody in el salvador i have to send
from western union to western union
there's no western union to chase bank
or western union to something else it's
western union to western union
in the united states if i'm on venmo and
john's on cash app i can't venmo john he
receives it on cash app they're all
closed networks
what the bitcoin network and the
lightning network allow for is an open
network and so now all of a sudden what
can happen is that i could be on the
moon wallet john could be on the chevo
wallet and even though i'm using a
different interface i can still use the
bitcoin network of the lightning network
and i can send value to john and he
receives it in his app or his interface
but we our two companies the companies
that we're using they don't even talk to
each other they don't even know anything
about each other right they don't have a
partnership on any of this stuff and so
when you look at a 10x improvement on
technology if you look at an open system
versus a closed system it's very clear
that there's going to be massive
disruption in the payment sector
because ultimately there's a financial
incentive and there's a user experience
incentive that allows you to uh
transact with more people in a more
efficient way faster and cheaper if it's
cheap convenient and secure people were
going to follow the technology of course
why would you pay and by the way we were
just talking i think it was a hundred
dollars is what uh mackenzie was talking
about it's a three dollar fee
right
yeah oh i'm sorry ten dollars so so
think about this if you wanna send ten
dollars you pay thirty percent fees
thirty 30 fees
you want to talk about some nefarious
ass [ __ ] there you go
if somebody wants to send ten dollars
from canada to el salvador they pay 30
to people that need it into a country
that needs it
yeah and it's also not instant right
like
to be honest it's robbery to be honest
it kind of just pisses me off right
because what you start to realize is
it's like the banks the top four banks
made eight billion dollars in 2019
off of overdraft fees they took eight
billion dollars from people who didn't
have money
same thing here if you're sending 10
across western union you're probably not
super well off
and the person that you're sending it to
probably really needs the money
but you charge 3.24 yeah the the problem
is though is uh this is their only
option right as of right now like though
historically that has been their only
option and the unfortunate part is it's
almost like you signed up for it right
so when you sign up for a bank you're
agreeing to hey if i overdraft my
account you can charge me that fee but
it's the people that don't really have a
lot of options to go to and they're like
hey look i need to set up an account
this bank i need to use this kind of
service and i'm willing to accept those
fees even knowing sometimes hey look i'm
gonna i'm gonna run into that issue
later and i'll deal with it when i get
there
the other piece of this that i think no
one's really talking about
is
as you drop costs so aggressively and
you create an open network what this is
going to do is it's going to uh spread
very virally money is the most viral
product in the world right and so if all
of a sudden now i can plug into a open
network and so can all of you when i
plug into that open network i can send
money to any of you but also every
single business that now joins i can do
it as well and so you're basically using
this common infrastructure in a way that
doesn't require intense centralized
coordination everyone is financially
incentivized to see the system work but
everyone does it on their own
perspective so you plug in your node
and you don't care if i have a node set
up or not as long as you plug into the
system the more nodes that are set up
the more coverage there is the more
coverage there is actually the more
efficiency there becomes and so what you
start to do is the network gets built
out by every individual participant and
the equal parts or like the total of the
sum
ends up being so much better right think
about this for a second 12 years ago
bitcoin was created
today
a nation of state has onboarded not to
just layer one but to layer to the
lightning network
an entire country is now saying they're
gonna use lightning network
and so you have mcdonald's right
starbucks big corporations do lots of
transactions you can go there right now
and you can buy items in the country as
legal tender using bitcoin the lightning
network is super exciting we're gonna do
a whole segment on that one day
this reminds me of like
the internet
in what way how long did it take for
countries to like take the world wide
web seriously
like you're asking all the great
questions guys the way you laugh at that
you're saying how long did it take for
at what point was the internet kind of
what bitcoin and how we're talking about
the lightning network and all these
things now for global adoption right no
nodes and yeah you have to remember that
a lot of people when they first saw the
internet
they couldn't wrap their head around the
use cases right
right so there's obviously the famous
video i think it's like brian gumbel
and a couple people and they're like
internet what's the internet all right
and they like are talking about it
you know you're like they're like
the internet and you're like no it's
just internet they're like
what is this the internet right and
you're everyone just like laughs about
the videos now
or there's paul krugman who was like you
know the internet will never be more
useful than to send like a or never be
more useful than a fax machine or
something
and so what happens is humans have a
really really hard time extrapolating
out a technology shift or like a
paradigm shift and how that will
actually end up being um implemented
later or like the the impact that it has
later
and so
bitcoin is like the manifestation of
that today where
who would have thought
that
50 plus percent of commerce in the
united states
would be on the internet now
who would have thought that eventually
you would press a button on your phone
and a car would show up who would have
thought that during a global pandemic
people could sit in their home and order
food and someone would deliver it to
them
right who would have thought that amazon
would end up getting into
same-day delivery
like these things are insane if you're
talking about it in 1990s
today we're like yeah duh of course like
hindsight 20 20. of course that was
gonna happen
chivo wall this is the tweet i was
looking for earlier
cnbc said el salvador's new bitcoin
wallet could cost western union 400
million dollars a year chivo wallet
sorry not sorry boys
i mean just expert level trolling right
now and so look at the end of the day
this is what it takes it takes people to
build technology takes people to
actually go out there do the work but
the writings on the wall the legacy
payment systems they have a choice
embrace the new technology that's all
this is this technology embrace the new
technology or get disrupted classic
innovators dilemma and usually what
happens in the innovator's dilemma is
that the legacy incumbent businesses do
not embrace the new technology because
it will eat away at their
current business if western union was to
go ahead and embrace bitcoin it could
hurt them to the tune of hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars a
year across the world
and so
are you going to make a decision as an
executive who you're graded by the stock
performance in the short term
that is going to hurt your stock price
today for the long term sustainability
and durability of your business usually
not and so what ultimately will happen
is they will continue to milk it as much
as they can they'll take as much revenue
as they possibly can but ultimately
they're just running off a cliff and
they'll end up getting disrupted what's
up guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]